you've heard of valorance greats tens
cnn yay
but what if i told you there was an
up-and-coming player who could be just
as exciting a human highlight machine
from a region where players don't get a
fair shot
what if i told you that india's sk rossi
could be valorant's secret superstar to
kill the kill of whoever these people
finding the kill
that's gonna
picked up mw1 oh sk rossi three kills
four this is huge from sk rossi and he's
looking for every single victim sk ross
he's got the ac he's got every single
player this man cannot be denied
sk rossi's incredible combination of aim
aggression and confidence has made him
the hottest star in india's burgeoning
valorant scene which is only getting
bigger
so we had to ask ourselves where did sk
rossi come from how did india get so
intervalrant and why do people keep
sending us tips that this guy is
actually forsaken ladies and gentlemen
we got him
in 2017 india's pc gaming scene was
scrappy but relatively small there were
a bunch of games that were popular
including cs go but indian teams weren't
exactly international superstars but
there was always an audience for
counter-strike for cs go and for dota 2.
um there are a lot of people who play
both those games or at least their way
but it just didn't translate to actual
competition for whatever reason though
that didn't stop esports orgs like optic
from trying to figure out if games like
cs could become mainstays in the country
but sk rossi's path to pro began with
dota 2 when his dad gave the 16 year old
his first desktop pc
in 2016 sk rossi won a tournament at a
local internet cafe and he quickly
became a constant presence there but for
a different game
i started going to that cafe very often
because pcs were nice and there was this
game called piercing and there were also
people playing that game from there i
was like really interested because the
atmosphere and the feeling when you play
something competitive and when there is
something on the line uh i i really like
that atmosphere and the feeling was
insane piercing blow or point blank as
it was known in some places launched in
india as a free-to-play game sk rossi's
team won the point-blank national
championships in india in both 2016 and
2017 even going to the 2017 world cup
but when pearson blow died sk rossi's
connections helped him transition to cs
go so after that again the game was shut
down in india so i had to
you know i was looking for any other
games to play and my friend introduced
me to counter strike go csgo so he's
like okay this is also an fps game why
don't you give it a try like in fact his
aim plus his sudden emergence made some
old-school indian cs pros wonder if
maybe he had some
assistance
i just want to make the crowd go crazy
with my nutty shots
i hope to eat some few of the wack shots
like the rumors are going around me that
i'm kind of a fishy player but sk rossi
was legit and once he proved he wasn't a
cheater he quickly became one of the
country's most exciting young players
unfortunately another pro who wasn't so
legit was about to strike a devastating
blow to indian esports
when forsaken was caught using cheats on
lan at xtremeland asia 2018 it ended
optic gaming's involvement with india
and for a lot of fans that was a
worrying sign for the whole country we
thought that optic would come out in
support of us and then
let us know that they got our backs and
you know at least until the trip was
over until we got back home to indian
soil but
all they said was uh we're shutting down
this division goodbye and there was no
funding support also from that point was
cut but forsaken's actions didn't
destroy all of counter-strike in india
in fact sk rossi was still killing it
and now this is gonna bite them in the
butt sk rossi still managing to land
some sweet one taps it doesn't matter
take out vexing oh my god he just [ __ ]
all over them dude what the hell should
be time for sk rossi to shine at 38
seconds and there you go he's gonna take
them four down
ladies and gentlemen look at this sk
rossi so he's gonna have to quickly make
his way onto the site and uh
yeah actually he doesn't even need
utilities man he's just got his bullets
point 50 caliber easy peasy gonna get
that aim straight to the face
put a bullet through the skull and uh
move on to the next enemy
all right so one versus two i'm gonna
spawn one more play all right so isolate
himself into a one versus one what
i told you
but in 2020 a game came out that forced
indian cs go pros to make a choice
with valerian's release indian cs go
players had a decision to make should
they stick to the game that they arrived
late to and struggled in internationally
or should they cut their losses and
switch over to a new untested title on
one hand valorent could be a fresh start
for the country's greatest stars on the
other it could also crash and burn but
then something else happened that
answered the question for them
in september 2020 the indian government
banned over 100 mobile phone apps
including the massively popular pubg
mobile citing security concerns over the
app's chinese operator tencent the app's
removal represented an escalation of
political tensions between the two
countries governments but it also meant
that the 175
million indians who downloaded the game
had to find something new to play or
watch in the case of the game's
streamers valrant comes up these guys
stream it and suddenly you have these um
literally millions of viewers overall
you combine some of the streamers
conquering numbers it's massive right
and suddenly they're exposed to
not just a whole different game but a
whole different sphere in itself which
is esports uh pc esports on top of all
of this was the fact that because of the
global pandemic pcs got more popular in
india in india generally people don't
buy pcs right not to the extent they do
in eu or na but since it was uh there
was a lockdown for such a prolonged
period almost over a year everyone
started buying pcs or
because you know they had lectures so
they could convince their parents you
know i want a pc for a lecture but it's
it's just for gaming as well right the
surge in valorance indian popularity
made switching games a lot more feasible
even for counter-strike die-hards a lot
of them switched over but in the process
a lot of newer players the the the
latest generation of
counter-strike players from the country
of which a couple of names would be like
sk rossi for example who came in very
late in the life cycle of cs go in india
official indian server support for the
regional launch in october 2020 and with
pubg still mia valorant exploded there
was a bit of transition from the the
mobile esports uh ecosystem so to speak
into valor and esports in particular in
the country which is why
right now it is
by far the biggest pc esports i have
ever seen in the region and that same
month sk rossi left cs behind and became
the first member of global esports new
valorant roster
but sk rossi started to get cocky so igl
hellranger sat down with the star sniper
to address his mentality with regards to
rossi you know
in the start he used to
get frustrated or
you know irritated when something didn't
go our way or something wrong happened
i sat and thought about this like if i
want to be a best player or skilled
player this is not the right
approach to the game i should be like
team based player like i need to help my
teammates and i also should think about
them not only about myself in spite of
whatever shortcomings he may have had
sk rossi stood out
gonna put out those compass sk rossi
finding the first ghost missouri he
fights the second one third fourth and
he might just get an ace i've actually
spoken to the velocity gaming guys uh
velocity esports guys who are their arch
nemesis in the in the region right and
and i asked him i'm like what is it with
you guys in global esports like
sometimes you win sometimes you lose
what's the x factor and
all of them
in unison we're like it says k rossi
sk rossi emerged as one of the scene's
most exciting players combining
explosive entry fragging with the off he
dared to dash and peak where others
hesitated it is a combination aboard him
being set up and also he's got his
mentality of sheer raw confidence he
doesn't care who's going to who's going
to be facing up against he's willing to
take that fight and he's so confident so
good at what he does it just comes out
on top hell ranger and another buddy
played that fence moment just two people
coming up on the ropes to secure the
kill on whoever they see
finding a kill
and his newfound fame led to an ironic
joke on april fools there were plenty of
fans who thought that sk rossi looked a
lot like forsaken hell one of our
writers even got an email tip claiming
that the two were the same person
so global esports leaned into the meme
in a way the whole thing was made
funnier by the circumstances the young
talent who could put indian pc esports
on the map was pretending to be the man
who almost destroyed it so many people
took our forsaken video like seriously i
used to get messages from philippines
singapore thailand also like it was not
only indians who thought forsaken me to
come back it's also people from outside
india's indian fans embraced valorent
and even after pubg mobile was
relaunched as the region locked
battlegrounds in mobile india valor and
esports continued to flourish
sadly india didn't get a guaranteed slot
for the valor and champions tour
instead a single team from south asia
would qualify for the 8-pack lcq by
winning the vcc or valorante conquerors
championship the vcc was scheduled for
late august and the first and second
indian teams to qualify were velocity
gaming and global esports but sk rossi
was struggling leading up to vcc he
moved into global esports facility his
first time away from home and to make
things worse he was dealing with
migraines that made it almost impossible
to practice so many things are bothering
me missing my family my health and also
people expectations and like they know
like when they see me they expect me to
get 30 kills every game so even if i get
25 it's the pressure like people started
telling you like you're not better than
this guy or not that comparison is used
to go on like okay cool nobody knows my
situation sk rossi pushed through it all
global esports made it to the grand
finals of vcc facing velocity gaming in
a five game series to determine who was
really india's best valorant team map
one split looked like an easy win for
global esports but it quickly slipped
away and it looked like despite the
progress sk rossi might not have been
able to make the difference his team
needed so he got irritated he was
frustrated and
he
it almost felt like he does not want to
play the game then i took him outside
and i told him
right now you don't have a choice
it is with this team
that you are going to play people are
going to make mistakes including you so
you need to just accept that fact and
play the next four maps if you play the
way you are playing right now
you are going to lose and the team is
going to lose all of us lose i know you
want to win but everyone else also wants
to win and it was just like
me saying that thing is one thing but
him just doing a mental switch was a
really good thing
sk rossi bounced back in map two and
three but after a loss on icebox it all
came down to map five ascent
global fell behind early they were down
nine to three at the half and victory
looked impossible
but sk rossi pulled through
he's beat able to show up
he's uh i got another kill picked up mw1
oh sk rossi three kills four this is
huge from sk rossi and he's looking for
every single victim sk ross he's got the
ants he's got every single player this
man cannot be denied looking to find
something they're giving him nothing
oh no oh my god
rossie what are you doing
12 10 one more kill and they've done it
ge are just a kill away from winning
this vcc and heading to the aipac last
chat qualifiers and who other than sk
rossi to close it out the champions of
the vcc are global esports they take
down vlt and now they're the champions
of the region india's representatives in
aipac when global esports won the series
esker rossi couldn't contain his
emotions any longer and he didn't have
to it always comes with the journey you
went through things you went through and
winning that tournament was you know it
meant so much to me even after they made
it into the last chance qualifier
expectations for global esports weren't
that high the other sca teams hailed
from historically stronger regions like
korea japan and singapore and some of
them had main stage vct experience
against much stronger teams a massive
upset win over korea's damon gaming got
the world talking but it was followed by
losses to paper rex and f4q
for sk rossi though even if winning
would have been better this was a good
start and a path forward counter-strike
wasn't a dead end for india valorant
gave them another chance to prove
themselves and whatever happens next you
can bet that sk rossi's unpredictable
style will continue to turn heads and
get clipped no matter where the region
goes
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our twitter
instagram facebook and tick tock